[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America I'm Dave Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose host of the Ken
Coleman show where he talks about jobs
and careers and your life about that
he's with me today as a co-host so we'll
particularly dive into those subjects if
you want to the phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money Joseph is in Indianapolis
hi Joseph welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you better than I deserve
what's up
well I had a pretty a simple question
um you know I I always hear you know two
sides of the coin I hear sometimes
people say you should make the most
money that you can and
um you know get a job that just pays the
most when I've heard other people say
that it's not about what you make it's
about how you live your life your
lifestyle and what you can say my guess
my question is is it still possible to
live a wealthy or successful life if say
you're only bringing in maybe thirty
five thousand dollars annually
well it depends on how you define wealth
you know
um I will tell you that you can
absolutely be successful
I'll ask you a question do you believe
Mother Teresa was successful
yes why was Mother Teresa successful in
your mind
she did a lot of good you know and and
uh and always try to do her best yeah
see the the reason I ask it that way is
because she that was her role it doesn't
mean it's your role doesn't mean we all
have to go to Calcutta but Mother Teresa
chose to serve to live in that way that
was her specific design her role her
time in history so success answer the
success question that way success to me
is not just about work results successes
uh what am I relationally I have a
relational purpose as a husband and a
father a son a brother a friend a
co-worker an employee I've got some
relationship purpose in my life but I
also have professional purpose so that's
the success thing now Building Wealth uh
again uh wealth to me is not just
Financial wealth but you can we've got
teachers that are the average salary not
average the median right now is about
sixty one thousand dollars in the United
States and we have a lot of millionaires
who have been teachers and they've lived
on less they've chosen to define success
differently and as a result they've put
money away and they've saved they've
lived like no one else and so now they
live and give like no one else so uh 35
000 does limit the speed and rate by
which you can stack and save money and I
think you can make more but but
theoretically yes you can be successful
and build wealth Earl Nightingale said
the definition of success is the
progressive realization of a worthy goal
or ideal
now so here's the problem with your
question
the framing of your question
uh you say two sides of a coin it's not
two sides of the coin uh they're two
possible outcomes okay uh either I don't
make a lot of money and I do something
that I'm fulfilled in and I'm successful
but I'm ha but I struggle financially
or I make a lot of money doing something
I hate and I don't struggle financially
those aren't the two only two possible
outcomes there's a third one how about I
do something I love that really benefits
Mankind and I make a huge pile of money
why do you have to make less to be
satisfied why do you have to make less
for it to have meaning you don't uh that
that's a that's a fatalistic approach to
this whole concept and so
um so here's the point if you make
thirty five thousand dollars a year and
that's all you ever make and you never
get a raise well you suck
you should get a raise you should have
some Progressive realization you should
proc you should have progress you should
get better at what you're doing and make
more money at least in your chosen field
so the idea that I have to you know
somehow live at the bottom rungs of the
socio-economic ladder in order to be a
worthy person or in order to be doing
good works is simply not true it's
simply not true so I choose none of the
above I choose do something very worthy
and make a lot of money
I choose that way that's the one I want
to choose but but is that the only
definition of success no I mean we've
pre-established in the conversation
Mother Teresa successful says a
progressive realization of a worthy goal
or ideal oh by the way she was the
biggest
and largest scale of her type
that's right I mean the number of hungry
people the number of people that were
ministered to was massive that's right
but not commensurate to the amount of
money she made or she's making money
that's right
took of our poverty that's true she
didn't make any money and she came from
a wealthy family that's exactly right
and abandoned The Inheritance in order
to become a nun so you know so so yes
she's successful and uh absolutely never
gonna diss someone that chooses to do
that but there's this narrative that is
running around in America today that Ken
and I are both fighting against all the
time on the career side that says um
well I if I work for a non-profit and
make half of what I'm worth that somehow
I'm Holier
no that was just a dumb choice
you're not Holier or well you don't
really mean that as a dumb choice you
don't mean that if you choose to work
for a non-profit because you care deeply
about that work and you could take the
same skill set and and make double in
the corporate world but you choose to do
it in that space because you love it and
you apply that to your life and you
change your lifestyle that's not dumb
but that's also not saying that it's
that what is dumb is the idea that the
only way that you can do something that
is of a higher calling and that has
meaning is to make no money I agree that
is just not true 100 agree I'm living
proof that that's not true that's right
I've helped millions and millions of
people and I made a lot of money right
making a lot of money was not the main
goal helping millions of people and and
but that you know I'm just I'm but we're
also citing we have done Ramsay
Solutions at Dave's urging the largest
study ever of net worth millionaires the
fourth largest group are School teachers
so they're not dumb third largest yeah
third I apologize thirdly but the point
here is my point you didn't mean what I
mean as the idea is dumb that you have
to make less for it to have meaning yeah
it's incomplete it's it's you're right
it's not accurate it's a false narrative
yeah and so that's what I want to push
back against and if you make 35 000 if
you make the same exact amount of money
unless your Mother Teresa you took about
poverty uh if you're if you're in a
career field and you make exactly the
same for 30 years that by definition
means you are not progressing yeah there
should be you're not getting better
that's not okay either yeah you need to
be getting better you need to be
better in your service to humanity
better in the level of meaning that
you're getting from the work better in
Your Excellence better in the scale of
what you're doing if helping three stray
dogs is a good thing then helping 3 000
of them is a better thing that's right
okay so I mean whatever it is you're
doing that you know you should be
getting better at it you should be
progressively yes the progressive
realization of a worthy goal or ideal
it's a really good definition
so one of the best cool question Cool
question and a good discussion but uh
don't let people sell you this idea that
that the only thing that is is good it
is unproductive
quite the contrary this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
we're so glad you're here Hey listen
guys there's a lot of things going on
inflation High interest rates student
loans are kicking back in we just passed
a trillion dollars in credit card debt
for the first time in history
wow a lot of people doing a really
crummy job with their money
you know what you don't do no one does a
crummy job on purpose
doing a crummy job is when you hit the
default button and just Coast
you know what on purpose is in money
it's learning to do a budget the every
dollar budgeting app will do that you
can sit down and start using that Jade
warshaw did a webinar today that was
free on how to do a budget including an
irregular income 10
000 people showed up for that webinar
today thank you wow so we'll do it again
Rachel Cruz is going to do one of these
webinars teaching you how to do a budget
and uh Rachel's been teaching every
dollar for many years and The Irregular
income thing and unpredictable income
and how to work the baby steps into your
budget and all that how to work with
your spouse on a budget Rachel's going
to cover every bit of that Tuesday
August 15th that'll be this coming
Tuesday at 12 30 p.m you can sign up for
free for the webinar and Rachel's goal
of course is to draw more people than
Jade
so this is how this works around Ramsay
I'm just saying so check it out
everydollar.com
budgeting
everydollar.com budgeting and you're
actually allowed to come to more than
one of these if you want guess what
George will be doing one later so hey
everydollar.com budgeting sign up for
the free webinar this coming Tuesday
August 15th with Rachel Cruz Elizabeth
is in Boston hi Elizabeth how are you
I'm good how are you thanks for taking
my call Dave sure what's up
um yeah so I am wondering I found you
last week
um and I am on baby step two and I am
wondering if I should be buying life
insurance beforehand or if I should be
waiting to after baby step two I do have
a 25 000 company-funded life insurance
policy I don't know if that's good
enough or if I should be buying one
um
that's you know more for the future if
you have a life insurance need it is not
a baby step it's a necessity in your
budget
yep so you just put it in there as soon
as possible now do you have children
no I am single and no children okay do
you have how much debt do you have
I have 44
000 and 700 in debt okay you don't have
a lot of need
for life insurance
yeah because no one is dependent upon
your income 25 000 would take care of
your final expenses like for instance
your parents or would have a horrible
tragedy on their hands and have to cover
the burial and that kind of stuff 25k
would take care of that it would clean
up a few of these debts they'd sell off
your stuff uh I think you're fine right
now I wouldn't I don't think you need to
be a bunch of life insurance even if you
had a hundred thousand dollars in the
bank and no debt I I particularly then I
wouldn't uh go buy life insurance but I
you know the big thing life insurance is
for is if you're leaving someone behind
that is dependent financially on your
income
okay yeah so you would wait until I
wouldn't buy it at all I wouldn't buy it
at all in your situation
okay that makes sense no matter what I
mean and now again you get married you
have two little kids yeah if they're
your husband then is dependent upon your
income to take care of these these
little kids yeah absolutely then we
start talking about life insurance and
we go to xanderinsurance.com and we uh
we always talk about A good rule of
thumb in a family situation like that is
to have 10 to 12 times your income on
you 10 to 12 times your spouse's income
on them 15 to 20 year level term
insurance never buy anything but term
insurance is the way to go and that
covers you until you don't uh uh until
you have so much money and no debt that
you don't have a need for insurance
called self-insured Stacy and I have
been married just a couple of years when
she went to work for Dave and I remember
seeing through Financial Peace
University as a spouse and I remember
this lesson when you covered it and I
had not gotten life insurance to that
point and I want people to hear this
isn't just life insurance this is peace
of mind I slept better that night
knowing that if anything happened to me
Stacy was going to be fine and it's just
that I want people to hear that it
really is peace of mind to know that
you're not leaving anything but grief uh
behind don't buy too much because then
you can't sleep at night because you
have to stay awake to make sure that she
that was a crucial point in the teaching
as well I did it to the book I did it to
the 10 times 10 times 10 to 12 times
yeah you don't need 20 times right we're
not trying to leave people multimedia
better off with you being gone it's just
a dangerous Trend right you know so
there we go open phone's a triple eight
eight two five five two two five James
is in Phoenix hi James how are you
hey dude Ken how you guys doing today
better than we deserve what's up
well my question to you Dave is I have
two cars that I owe a lot of money on
and I'm upside down and I need to get
rid of them so I can start paying off
that I am surrounding in debt
it's hard okay car number one is you oh
what on
card number one is uh 30 000 or excuse
me thirty one thousand a little over
thirty one thousand okay and what's it
worth
uh probably about 18 to 20. where'd you
get that number
uh I actually got it on the blue the.com
Kelly Blue Book
kellybluebook.com okay and is that a
trade-in value
uh honestly I didn't know I just got
that's the number that they gave me I
didn't really look into it yeah you need
to look into it because the difference
in trading and Private Sales five grand
in this situation
it makes a lot of difference okay so
because what is that car
uh it's a Volkswagen T1 it's uh what
year
uh 2019
okay did you trade a negative equity car
into that deal
uh we traded a a car that was paid off
that just had repeat it was actually a
older T1 and I mean you didn't you
didn't trade a hole into this this whole
so that 18 000 is wrong then okay good
good okay so you didn't have like a five
thousand dollar hole you were in on the
other car it was paid off so it was a
positive in the trade
yes sir okay all right so uh yeah from
2019 that that Volkswagen did not go
down that far okay so it's probably 25
000 car 24 000 car something like that
so you need seven Grand to get out of
that who do you owe that money to who's
the bank uh Credit Union First Credit
Union okay what about the next car
next car is a Jeep Renegade 2019.
and I owe 30 a little over 30 000 on it
and what's it supposedly worth
I have not checked it yet okay all right
so 2019 was a bad year for you on cars
pretty much yeah
okay who's that loan with
same same company first good good and
this is Credit Union in your town
yes sir good Phoenix Arizona good okay
so let's pretend you're seven thousand
bucks uh 7 500 upside down on each of
them that's fifteen thousand dollars in
a hole we are in correct yes sir and you
have sixty thousand dollars worth of
good debt and 15 000 of it's not secured
because there's not enough car value to
cover it right yes so you need to go in
person to the credit union sit down with
a credit union manager
and show them what you've got
and here's what you say to him or her
you have a 45 you have forty five
thousand dollars worth of collateral
so effectively you have a fifteen
thousand dollar unsecured loan
Mr Credit Union manager
you following me here
because you owe 60. the assets aren't
worth but about 45 give or take
so what I would like to propose to you
is that we sell both of these cars and
reduce the loan here by as much as the
cars bring a hundred percent of what the
cars bring is going to come into you
and I'm going to sign a note for the
difference
so when we're finished you'll still have
an unsecured note but you'll have
someone who's much better able to pay it
because it's a much smaller loan
you understand the logic that you're
pitching to this Credit Union manager
I'm writing it down now yeah they
already have a unsecured note we're just
admitting it
that's all we're trying to get them to
do and it reduces your debt from 60 down
to 15 give or take in this scenario and
then you're going to get you a couple
thousand dollar garage sale cars to
drive for a little while which is going
to be a big old emotional punch in the
nose from a thirty thousand dollar car
to a one thousand dollar car
you're gonna feel like a poor person
well you are so we're trying to not be
poor anymore that's the idea so we're
trying to reset that this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial piece and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Tristan is with us in Albany New York hi
Tristan welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello so excited to speak with you you
too what's up
so I was calling because I want to know
or maybe get any advice on how to use
the money that I have saved to make me
more money rather than just letting it
put in a savings account and
do nothing
good question
how much money have you saved Tristan
so I I have money kind of um I've been
trying in the last couple months to put
it in different places so
um if I just looked at all of the money
that I have that is free to be put
wherever I please
um it's 68 000 good for you okay and
what do you make
uh I don't make much actually I'm I'm
still in graduate school so um what are
you studying
I I study mathematics yeah what are you
gonna do
well that's another question so I'm kind
of at a Crossroads with my career and
what I want to do what is the grad
school program
mathematics you're going to get a PhD in
math or math yes sir yeah a PhD in math
but uh I I'm debating on whether I'm I'm
going to continue that or just finish
with a Masters or not
um so that's kind of where I'm at a
Crossroads but um I have I've been
saving a lot of money and uh where's the
money coming from
so I as a part of a graduate student I I
get like a salary basically it's 23 000
for this year but I do summer work uh
for the Air Force
um which was seventeen thousand dollars
um
and before as an undergrad I I have
worked the whole time so I've been
working and saving and that's where the
money has been coming from all right so
quick question before we dive into the
money piece and and I can talk to you
about the work piece after that but when
you say I'm considering not finishing
what's that timeline look like how much
do you have left where you're deciding
between the doctorate versus to the
Masters well how far along are you yes
so if I finish my masters it'll be one
more year and then I can start my career
uh if it's my doctorate it it's not
really a set time it could take uh three
to five more years
in this case is the difference in the
doctorate and the master is not just a
dissertation
why would that take three to five years
write your dissertation
work you
more material outside of what is taught
in classes and that you have to learn
enough to get a dissertation done
yes sir yeah the difference is do I want
to be a professional student or do I
want to get my PhD exactly so get your
PhD go do the dissertation it does not
take three to five years it takes 12
months get it done but what happens is
people drag their butt around that's why
I was asking about that and don't I you
know you're you're that close depending
on what you want to do with your life if
you want to teach right in the in the in
the uh at the University level you're
going to need the PhD
right right but I don't think you're
sure if you're going to be a financial
analyst on Wall Street nobody gives a
crap between the two
that's yeah that's that's where I I
think I've had this dream of getting a
doctorate because
it's an accomplishment and it's
something that I can say that I did and
worked hard for well Dr Tristan I mean
come on buddy I mean yeah but but you
need to have a reason to you need to
have a reason to do it because you're
running out of steam I can hear it so uh
yeah you know and the only reason to do
it is if Ken Coleman says okay in this
career field that's right you're gonna
need a PhD yeah but in that career field
you're not then don't then I wouldn't
screw with it I really wouldn't and my
guess is Tristan tell me if I'm wrong my
guess is the fields that require the PHD
aren't they aren't the dinner bell for
you you're not excited about them is
that true or false
he uh that's that's true that's that's
true I I think I realized how much work
it is in the uh trade-off for the amount
of pay exactly and and I just said what
am I doing kind of so that's what you
always measure with academics other than
the the benefit of just having you know
completed something the accomplishment
of it the Dr in front of your name all
that stuff but the the the the real
benefit of academics the primary benefit
is what how does it change your income
situation so whatever the academic thing
is so yeah it's from paycheck to
purposes Ken's book we will send you a
copy so when we finish talking we'll put
you on hold and uh Austin the gang in
the booth will pick that up and get get
that for you now for savings there's
three things philosophically you can do
with savings number one you can have a
pile of money set aside to cover for
emergencies and you should a good rule
of thumb is three to six months of
expenses as an emergency fund number two
we thing we use savings for is to buy
things we save up and buy a house we
save up and buy a couch we save up and
buy a car and so on and these are all
real things that are coming at you so
you need some savings to move towards
those things the third reason we save is
not really saving it's called investing
which is really what you're calling
about is how do I make this money work a
little harder for me
how do I make it make some money so some
portion of the 68 000 needs to be
invested and that's where you would
start looking at retirement are you out
of debt
so yes that's that's one of the things
that I have not I have not worried too
much about staying in school because I
have worked and I have gone scholarships
and I have gone to colleges where I have
graduated debt free I've never taken out
a loan and uh and you can you know you
can start with some Roth IRAs and some
good growth stock mutual funds let that
money grow completely tax-free for your
retirement year some portion of that
needs to be there and those mutual funds
uh you know if they average what the
stock market has averaged over the last
80 years will be 10 to 12 percent rate
of return you're probably getting spit
or maybe you're getting four percent on
some kind of high yield item or whatever
but you're still losing your butt so a
portion of it needs to be invested in
that type of thing a portion of it needs
to be set aside for making the
transition into your new career you know
getting an apartment at the new city uh
deposits the move those kinds of things
a portion of it is used for emergencies
only and you need to set that aside and
so I would divvy the 68 up among those
three categories or buckets and sit down
with a smart investor Pro you can find
somebody that we recommend to help you
that we call them smart investor pros at
ramsaysolutions.com they'll help you get
that Roth IRA up and moving but more
important than the question you called
about by far is the question Ken is
posing to you and that is what are you
going to do with your life ma'am yeah
and you've got to decide here there's a
couple things to look at look at what do
I do very well you've chosen mathematics
you've been a good student there's
something that intrigued you about
numbers I'd start digging into what
comes naturally to me what I enjoy doing
then you begin to look at what does work
do at the end of the day work does two
things it solves a problem or it meets a
desire and so when you begin to go all
right Dave what like what what problems
do I want to solve with this Talent of
numbers and I'm just making this up with
him but we begin to see the clues like
that and we say all right I get fired up
about solving this problem or meeting
this desire let me tell you what we can
tell from what he told us he's not
thrilled about teaching numbers
he's not that's just not something he's
really fired up about that PhD leads him
a couple of Pathways I did not hear him
spending his life in Academia I did not
either I didn't hear that in his voice
but I could be wrong I could be wrong I
agree so I was a math nerd but
um you know highly Money Motivated math
nerd and so immediately that meant I
didn't get a degree in math right I got
a degree in finance instead exactly and
because I was Money Motivated I'm
looking how I can make some money
um but you love instructing you love tea
oh I do I do and I love and I love math
yeah it's a it's a gifting area so look
at Dave this is a combo so Dave's gifted
at communication but he's also gifted
with finance and numbers it's just
unbelievable but what he loves to do is
teach guide coach that's who he is you
ought to see this guy trying to teach
people to water ski he's as passionate
about that as he is teaching you how to
win with your money that's the combo
what is he good at what does he love to
do when those two come together there's
a whole lot of world at work where you
can go out there and make a contribution
and make plenty of money doing it hey he
probably needs to take that assessment
he does hang on we'll get you the get
clear assessment clear assessment and
yeah that'll help too we'll get you that
in his book both this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
to make your own medical decisions is a
big deal these days Christian Healthcare
Ministries gives members the freedom to
choose the doctors and providers they
want without the frustration of worrying
about networks and with no waiting
period to join it's a membership-based
non-profit Ministry where hundreds of
thousands of Christians share funds to
pay for and pray for each other's
medical bills for over 40 years chm has
helped families living across all 50
states so cfchm could be right for your
family check out more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host thank you for being with us
America open fountains a triple eight
eight two five five two two five Lucas
is in Midland Michigan hi Lucas how are
you
good Dave good uh good Ken how are you
guys doing today good better than we
deserve what's up
perfect well first off thank you for uh
taking my call it is uh much appreciated
sure sure uh before I get to my question
I'll just give you guys a couple or a
little bit of a back story with numbers
um we are currently a family of three uh
with one on the way coming April 2024. I
am 29 and my wife is 31.
currently we're making uh take-home pay
thirteen thousand five hundred dollars
per month which does not include my
wife's uh quarterly RSU stock options
that comes out to about twenty thousand
dollars a year or five thousand dollars
a quarter greater than sixty percent of
my of our income comes from my wife and
I just dropped down part-time as an ICU
nurse because I'm going to nurse
practitioner school coming up end of
August
um the VA is paying 100 for it um so I
won't take on any more debt
I'm not actually paying me a stipend
about 950 per month we're newly debt
free just entered baby step three
um August 1st after paying about 121 000
off worth of debt
um we will have our fully funded
emergency fund are six months by
December 1st and then we'll be
transitioning obviously into baby step
four five and six my wife's the bread
maker and over the last year and a half
two years there's been a couple of
rounds of layoffs um and with my wife
being the bread maker me going back to
school and then working part-time it
just has me a little bit nervous as we
work our way towards paying off our
mortgage early during school for the
first year and a half
um our cash margin will be seven
thousand dollars um and that is after
retirement and funding two 529s for our
kids once I graduate school they'll all
our margin will be about eighty three
hundred dollars cash we currently have a
home mortgage at 460 000.50 Lucas what's
your question
is would it be okay for us to go ahead
and bump our emergency fund to 9 to 12
months
and then um once we why
my biggest concern is my wife's losing
her job how many times has she lost her
job
never okay you're a worry Ward
I am very much a planner
um no you're aware
probably
probably so to a fault you know with us
being newly out of debt
um you know I I think that has a lot to
play in it Hey listen if you give me a
probability that she's got a 50 or
better chance of losing her job we'll
talk about getting ready for that storm
but right now this is just
you just you're just a planner that's
all this is and you're you're great
you're very intentional you know your
numbers you're amazing you guys have
done a great job I'm picking at you I
was having some fun with you but
congratulations I'm proud of you you've
done a wonderful job if you want to save
that you can do whatever you want to do
you're a grown-up I wouldn't if I were
in your shoes I don't think it
represents
uh anything except you are just overly
conservative and you're you just worry
you just read about things and the the
change with the new baby coming there's
gonna be four kids in the house the
change with you stepping back in income
while you're stepping up into this new
role by the way I think your your field
of study is brilliant I would go that
way I love it it's got a great upside
you're gonna you're gonna make really
good money you can help a lot of people
uh you can add value to a lot of
people's lives so everything in this
situation is positive and it's just
there's a lot of stuff coming at you and
the only way you knew to kind of buffer
that emotionally was pile up some extra
cash if you want to you're not it's not
going to cause you to
um to never be wealthy it's not dumb
it's just I I'm just calling you out on
it's not necessary
Lucas what I would have you do Lucas I
want you to take that planner in you and
Dave's right you got a lot of worrying a
lot of fear in this but let's take the
planning and let's say all right what
would happen what would we do what would
my wife do if she got laid off
now that I like it's like the idea of
going on the plane and they always tell
you if we were to have a landing a water
landing this is what we would do and I
think it's always smart for you guys to
just walk through not from a place of
worry but from a place of preparation
well the idea is if she were to get laid
off I'm just thinking about the jokes I
know I know but what would she do what
would you two do I mean she would go get
another job exactly you wouldn't even
have to touch the emergency fund knowing
how disciplined the two of you are you
guys have proven it so think about that
and don't be worried be prepared there's
a difference well he's trying to get
prepared that's what he's thinking but
oh I get it but I'd like that energy
going towards all right would it be the
end of the world what would she do
if you if you'll go to pin to Ken's
point if you
project out what reality looks like not
what the atom bomb dropping on your
house looks like in reality looks like
she probably is off a month or two gets
another job and gets a big severance
package and so you end up coming out
ahead that's Pro that's your high
probability if something went down like
this but um but yeah if if you guys want
to do this it's not the end of the world
is it financially
is a good financial planning is it
necessary are you being no you're just
overplaying your hand that's all you're
doing so um you can do it you're grown
up you're smart people you make a lot of
money there's nothing wrong with what
you're talking about but you asked so
we'll always tell you the truth because
we love you all right Kaylee is with us
in Grand Rapids hi Kaylee welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thanks for having me sure what's up
um I am calling because my husband and I
we are in baby steps uh four five and
six right now good
um we are looking to in the future
um move from our current house to
another one good um and wanted some
advice on on that
um we don't need to move right now but
we would like to move to a lake we know
you like Lake yeah so you might also
appreciate this
um
we came across a house that we would
potentially pay around seven hundred
thousand oh so this went from future
Theory to we're doing it now
sort of
um we're not sure and that's why we're
that's why I'm calling
um so I can give you kind of our stats
what would your house bring
the house we live in right now yes ma'am
we think we could sell it for
um at least
400.60 160. okay so you got 101 400 100
000 worth of equity give or take okay
and the other house you're talking about
purchasing on the lake is how much
uh 700. okay and what are you guys
making here
around 270. good good okay well you you
probably know our rule of thumb if you
don't it is that if you buy a home with
a 15-year fixed rate mortgage and the
payment is no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay and your take-home pay
being after taxes not after everything
that they deduct at work okay but after
taxes if your take-home pay and your pay
house payment on a 15-year fix is no
more than a fourth then you're okay and
you reach over and do that I think
you're okay
see what do you
want me to see when we do the math to us
a 30 years I mean I know I know what you
wouldn't buy a 30 year if you got to do
a 30 year don't don't move
well enough I think right now we're like
well with with the payments like 650 000
payment or 5650 000 debt what's the
payment come out
so our math it looks like it'll be
around for a 30 it'd be around 30. honey
we're not doing a 30. what was the 15
yeah and your take-home pays what 20.
it's 12 after no not on 270 it's not 12.
you don't bring home 144 out of 270.
401ks and other stuff yeah I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
okay I said after taxes only
okay
we didn't do that math so I think
I've done the math yeah yeah and so
one-fourth of your take-home pay after
taxes not after 401k and health
insurance those are two different things
okay and not after I pay some Bill at
the credit union or I pay child support
or whatever out of my check that's not
that's not what we're talking about
we're just talking about after taxes
that's the position you want to be in
and you do a 15-year Kaylee or don't buy
this house
you're making a mistake don't be playing
footsie with 30-year mortgages you'll
end up with one don't do it don't do it
was I unclear I I think you got it this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships open phones
at this hour can Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host he is the host
of the Ken Coleman show number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose helps with your career your
work goals and we'll talk about that as
a part of the program always open phones
here triple eight eight two five five
two two five Evan in Houston starts this
hour hi Evan how are you
I am wonderful how are you gentlemen
doing today better than we deserve sir
how can we help awesome yeah I have a I
have a quick question so I essentially
have 26 000 and between credit card and
student loan debt
um so my question is should I
temporarily pause on my 401k
contributions to pay down that debt
punch it in the face
um I've I've gotten about a hundred and
thousand dollars in my 401k right now
after only about five years of
contributing to it a lot of that comes
from I was contributing 13 of my salary
and 11 of my bonus payouts I get some
pretty big bonus sales every now and
then
um what do you mind curious your
thoughts
um that's what my wife and I make
between like I said depending on my
bonuses between 1 30 to 170. good for
you okay yes sir well if you're uh
wanting to We Believe around here and
we've proven that belief to be true that
your number one
wealth building tool is your income
what follows that means that getting out
of debt is a key to Building Wealth
because you're not giving all your money
to somebody else in the form of payments
right and that's kind of what you woke
up and realized the other day and you
said I need to get rid of this Dad now
how do I best do that now what we have
figured out is personal finance is about
80 behavior and only about 20 head
knowledge so the biggest and most
important thing you can do to get out of
debt is get so pissed off that nothing
else matters until you get the debt
cleared
you gotta get really mad at that and be
done with it you get the cards out have
a plastic surgery party we're only using
debit cards we're not going out to eat
we're not going on vacation we're going
to stop everything we're going to clean
up as freaking mess we make too much
money to have all this debt this is dumb
I'm stopping this and that's the talk in
your head you follow me
that's the talk that's been in my head
for a little while now so in the name of
that temporarily stopping your 401k
contributions regardless of how much
money you have in there regardless of
your age
temporarily stopping in the name of
Total Focus
because Total Focus matters when you're
trying to hit a big goal
in the name of Total Focus we're going
to temporarily stop your 401k it's
mathematically incorrect on the short
term on the long term once you clear the
debt and you stay out of debt for the
rest of your life because you understand
the power of focus now mathematics start
to work for you then and what little you
lose and match or what little you lose
in compound interest or opportunity cost
on the money will come back roaring back
in your future decades and so you're
going to be you know you're going to be
retiring of what we call a baby steps
millionaire following the baby steps and
baby step two is we attack the debts
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything but the little one yeah it
works every time every time Evan and it
seems like he's got the voice in his
head that he needs to have and I would
be Beyond pausing the 401K I'd be making
extra money if you have some skills that
you can get in the gig economy or the
freelance economy you can make a lot of
extra money in a lot of different ways
in this economy right now we still have
a white hot job market and don't ever
forget beyond the sacrifices and pausing
the 401K bringing more income in is also
a way to fast forward this process yeah
and it's just it's but you sit down with
your spouse and agree that we're going
to sacrifice we're going to live like no
one else so that later we can live and
give like no one else because with no
payments man you can build wealth for
sure Melanie Is With Us in Phoenix hi
Melanie welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Ken it's an honor to talk to
you both today you too what's up
so my husband and I are in baby steps
four and six I'm a nurse and he's a
teacher
and we're wondering if we should sell
our house and use the money for me to go
back to school to become a certified
registered nurse anesthetist
and we want to move to New Mexico
because it's one of the cheaper programs
and it has a really cheap cost of living
there
so yeah we want your advice on how to go
about this
how much would you make on your house
we've probably met about a hundred
what's your husband do you said he's
what a teacher teacher he's a teacher so
he would go to New Mexico and teach
there
yes to live this goal okay and you can
go to school there for nurse anesthesis
for what kind of money
uh the tuition would be about 90k plus
you know books and fees how old are you
guys
I'm 35 he's 34. okay
absolutely I would do this yep I would
too no-brainer I absolutely would do
this
it's a great move
because you have thought through all the
all the pitfalls and traps of a decision
like this and you closed every one of
the doors in in just how you presented
it to us I mean here's the thing I'm
going to go to the most inexpensive
school I'm going to get a degree that
pays where you'll just be stacking cash
I mean we're talking about 300 350 a
year you're making and you're gonna
spend 90 bucks 90 grand to go do that
and we got to move to the place where
the cheap school is anyway so while
we're at it let's sell the house use the
money to pay cash for that thing and
then we can buy anything we want to buy
later yeah ding ding I'm doing this
awesome I think you're I think that was
a very good critical thinking skills on
your own part what's your husband's is
he excited about this too
oh yeah we he's uh he's yeah over the
moon we have family there actually his
family is there so wow it's even better
yeah are you over the moon are you just
pretty chill in the way you show it
no I'm excited okay good all right I'm
ready yeah I'm ready for this because I
heard that pause when when we said that
but let me touch up this is a brilliant
move and you have a lot of freedom after
the fact even if in that again you got
family there but making this move also
allows you to decide to move anywhere
you want to down the line I'll be honest
it says on my screen should we sell our
house so I can go back to school when I
read that the first thing through my
head is she's gonna go get a degree in
left-handed puppetry and I'm gonna have
to tell her not to do this and I'm so
happy the call went another Direction
yeah I yeah yeah I'm so happy that but
Austin typed on the screen was just a
glimmer a glimpse into how brilliant you
guys are yeah yeah
we just needed your seal of approval
that was really you don't need my seal
of approval but I'll give it I mean I if
I were in your shoes I would do this I
love the degree field you're going into
I love the way you're going about
getting the education the least
expensive way to go get the thing
because I got to tell you we've been in
situations many times where there's a
nurse anesthesis in the room generally
when babies were being delivered and
things like that not one time that I
asked any of them where they went to
school
not once then we go wait a minute wait a
minute where's your degree from
how much did you pay for that degree not
once did we ask this question all we
asked was do you know how to do an
epidural you know I mean that's it
that's the whole thing baby oh my gosh
wow
[Music]
wow very cool that's neat yeah brilliant
move good good good I like somebody's
got the education thing figured out
education is not what matters knowledge
is what matters knowledge is the
currency
of the marketplace go get knowledge
that's what you need this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
home buying Market but there's a way you
can get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thanks for joining us the Ramsay
show question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services neighborly is the place to find
Reliable help for your home from trusted
locally owned businesses like Mr
Appliance Mr Handyman and Precision
garage door service great company visit
neighborly.com good folks to find home
experts available to serve you today's
question comes from Nathan in Virginia I
have a potential job opportunity but
feel guilty going for something else I
used to be a teacher but tried my hand
at Carpenter a few years back I love the
job in my company but every employee is
vastly underpaid even with raises the
prospects are not great I've been
approached about another opportunity but
feel guilty leaving this small company
has a family feel and taught me
everything I know plus I have become
their only skilled painter so I would be
leaving them kind of high and dry what
should I do well the first thing is to
reframe the feelings that you're feeling
you're a good guy Ethan because only
good people ask a question like this
this way first and foremost reframing it
means are you doing something illegal by
leaving this small family company the
answer is no are you doing something
unethical not if you leave the right way
so we're not having anything to feel
guilty about what you're feeling is a
sense of will they speak poorly about me
when I leave because it is a small
company and they do count on me and they
have taught me a lot I think you feel
some loyalty with a sense of sadness and
then I think ultimately you're afraid of
what they're going to say about you and
that's what's concocting these feelings
so there's nothing to feel guilty about
because you're not doing anything wrong
for considering and if you were to leave
you're not doing anything wrong so in
this situation if there's a lid on you
and you have another opportunity to grow
your finances because it's a bigger
company and they're offering better pay
go do it leave with class leave the way
you would want someone to leave you you
that would be my advice and if you do
that there should be no guilt
Nathan the
quality of the people you work for will
be revealed
on how they act when you leave
so I had a young man when the internet
there was this new thing called the
internet that started up several years
ago
and I had a young man that learned um uh
the coding skills
and he self-taught himself one of the
codes that's not used anymore but one of
the languages but it was big back then
when the internet was brand new called
cold fusion
and um
he built our first little website and
said you know Dave we could sell stuff
on this thing called the internet and I
just laughed I thought that'll be the
day and um it shows what I know but um
so he did and he was actually had
another job working for us but he did
that and and so he was our he was our
internet guy he was the only guy that
nobody could spell cold fusion but him
and and then he goes you know we could
get a little bit better at this she said
if I went to uh went to a class over in
Oklahoma you know it's 4 500 if I go
over there I could really make this
thing make some money I can show you how
to do this and I went well all right
let's do it because it's starting to
work we're starting to make a little
money on it I mean this was dial up you
know you remember
you know that was the internet right we
need that sound effect James yeah so um
anyway I sent him to Sir Oklahoma said
he spent 4 500 and back then 4 500 is a
lot of money for us that was it was we
were a little bitty company and he had a
daughter that had a a four-year-old
daughter had a medical condition and it
was expensive to take care of her
and he came back and he's working on it
and two weeks later he came in he goes I
got a real problem Dave
and I'm like what's the problem he goes
well you know I was paying him I think
40 000 bucks a year or something and um
he goes this company offered me a
hundred and forty thousand dollars wow
to come to work for him since I know
cold fusion and I went wow that's cool
and he goes yeah but you just paid four
thousand five hundred dollars
for me to go do this and that's why I
got the opportunity because it's not
right for me to leave I said Son you
have a daughter as a medical condition
somebody just offered you way more money
than I can pay you or will pay you even
if I could so here's what we're going to
do I'm gonna help you pack your desk I'm
so excited for you yeah and he went I
mean this was a upturn in the old days
when the internet was taken off and
everybody suddenly a code guy a person
that could do code was very valuable and
and uh so it's like I I I mean I love
that guy I want his little kid to be
taken care of and he can make a hundred
thousand dollars more than I could pay
him or was paying him yes he should take
that job and so that's how those people
should act
when you come in and quit yeah that's
exactly right not oh you're my only guy
and I just spent four thousand dollars
on you and oh man
you can't do that that's just called low
class I mean and by the way uh while
they will be probably disappointed uh
and it will be inconvenient you are
replaceable I have found that to be true
about everybody and so they they're
really sad how quickly we're all
replacing it's so true isn't it I mean
they're gone 10 minutes you're going
forgot they were here right yeah all of
us they'll survive they took they take
me off a radio station some City and 10
minutes later nobody remembers it you
know I was like I guess I wasn't
memorable no it's just the way people go
on they're going with their own lives
hello you know that's the way it works
Jacqueline's with us in Orlando Hi
Jacqueline welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um so I am currently working full-time
with my husband and I am looking to go
part-time for personal reasons I have
two little ones and
um there are in different therapies
medical reasoning so I want to be able
to be a more active mom and take them to
a zero therapy sessions but we've been
in a lot of debts and we've been working
the baby steps getting out and we still
have 90 000 to go and my entire paycheck
goes to those sets and I'm just kind of
confused and scared that I will go back
to where we were before if I do go
part-time
have the kiddos been going to therapy
pre prior to this phone call like
they're going now or is this going to be
a new rhythm
uh my daughter's been going but my son
is going to be starting up who's been
taking your daughter
um I have been
so your employer allows you that
flexibility
they did but now that's going to change
why is it changing
uh New Management
my old boss is no longer my boss okay
what kind of therapy are they doing hon
um what does your husband make
um
right now is
and what's yours
my take on this boarding what will you
be making when you go part-time
uh 20. what do you do
customer service
what else could you do that would make
more part-time
working from home
[Music]
um
I looked at working from home part-time
there's much
there's a lot out there
okay yeah
um
right because the holidays are coming
just to get a job at like a store no no
no no
listen I I
you've got to take care of your babies
and you're doing the right thing but you
don't have to accept
half the pay
because you're not doing something that
is like
something I trained for my whole life
and now I'm going to walk away from it
or something like that
um you're you're doing a job that is
this you can definitely pick up some all
kinds of hours and do things from home
and work around the therapy schedules
and work around the time with the kids
that's right yeah so I I don't think you
have to I think you guys can make it on
80. okay and you'll eventually wander
your way out of debt and if it slows
down you're getting out of debt because
you got to take care of babies then you
got to take care of babies that's just
the way life is
but you don't have to go all the way to
the you don't have to just keep the same
job at half I I would look for something
where I can make 30. just for the fun of
it just let's upgrade this you might
make 40 part-time Yeah by messing around
with it well this is a season so
Jacqueline I'd be looking at changing
your hours customer service reps are
very valuable if you can work evenings
even from home and you're still there
when the kids are in bed yeah you and
your husband need to sit down and figure
out schedules so that you have the
daytime to take the kiddos to the
appointments but you can work at night
time this is for a season this is
gazelle to get out of that ninety
thousand then we can reset it's not
forever it's just a it's what are we
going to do right now while the kids are
in therapy and we're trying to clear
this debt because working that this
other job's not going to work out the
current thing's not gonna work yeah I
agree with you that you got to change it
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
yeah
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
by their
100 percent satisfaction guarantee and
shipping shipping is always free see
whyblinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings go
to blinds.com now and save 45 off
selected products visit blinds.com today
for more info
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today hey
guess out we would appreciate it you can
do that a couple of ways one is you can
click follow or subscribe on your
podcast your YouTube channel whatever it
is you're doing follow us subscribe us
all that kind of stuff click the like
buttons always that kind of stuff leave
a nice five-star review and share the
show that's the important thing
tell people about where you're listening
to it some some of the services
depending on the type of podcast or
whatever it is have a share button maybe
you're watching us on TBN tell people
that and then you can see us there tell
people about your local talk radio
station that's carrying us however it is
share and talk about what's going on
over here at Ramsey because there's a
lot of positive things happen a lot of
people getting out of debt changing
their lives getting their careers
straightened out getting their mental
health lined up it's pretty amazing and
we are seeing as pretty sizable increase
in the number of you that are there in
the particular
different on the different on the
different platforms and thank you for
that thanks for sharing and thanks for
telling people about it uh for instance
this last week we became number 12 out
of all Apple podcasts
there's like four and a half million of
them Ramsay shows number 12. and that
matters here's why it matters the little
the little tiles they're in rows of six
so that means we're on that second row
right there I mean number 13 you don't
get anywhere near the visibility 14. but
we're way up there at the top and that's
because you guys keep telling people
about us thank you thank you thank you
for that we appreciate that Samantha is
with us in Long Beach hi Samantha
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi there thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
so I recently uh closed on condo my
first home purchase in January and
um just this last month the HOA board
voted to approve a special assessment
they're saying it's an emergency special
assessment to the tune of 33 000 per
unit good Lord
I know I know and they want it paid
um over six months uh payments of 5500
starting on September 1st
so I have my emergency fund of about 10
000 I've been working to get it up to 15
for my three to six months
um so I'm going to have to use that I'm
my parents are going to be able to help
me what is the assessment for
so they're saying it's for
um to remove and replace decayed wood
surfaces perform stucco repair
um so the exterior of the condos looks
like crap
correct yeah and they're saying there's
water damage and you knew you saw that
when you drove up to buy the condo
you know it has zero years life left so
I was expecting some kind of assessment
but nowhere in the reserve assessment
does it say anything near this amount
um
so they're basically seeing the reserve
s the reserve studies wrong
um you know construction costs are way
up labor costs their way up
um but this amount really there's 46
units they're saying it's 1.5 million to
do all the work
um so the amount itself I was expecting
maybe 20 like I could so you anticipated
something but you're just not this much
okay yeah all right so now what's your
question my question is should I I
guess
should I plan when I build back up my
emergency fund should I plan to have a
little extra because there's also the
roof that's going to need to get done
and they just don't collect enough they
don't accrue enough fees really hoacs to
adequately fund the deterioration cost
each year so I'm wondering if I should
if I should pad my emergency fund more
because of this no what do you make
I make about 155 after my bonus each
year
um I'll tell you what it would do though
I'd get involved in the HOA board
um enough that you get some people fired
and some different people serving that
actually and and change the fee
structure because like you said they're
not collecting enough to do their
sinking funds for their deteriorating
asset and that should be part of a
standard HOA fee
right and they're saying that they want
to keep the HOA fees low because well
that's just artificial it's artificial
if you're not collecting enough to
replace the parking lot you're not
collecting enough to replace the roof
based on the life it has left that's
called a sinking fund then the HOA fee
being low is artificial because you're
going to make it up with lump sum
special assessments there's always
you're going to live from emergency to
emergency this horrible management
yeah I agree yeah so yeah they need to
be fired you probably ought to get a
professional Condo Association
Management Company to oversee the board
they they do have one oh they suck yeah
yeah they do okay all right so yeah they
need to get fired and you need to get
some new people on the board because you
gotta you need to establish the fee
structure that takes care of the
property
individual homeowners have to do the
same thing I own a house if the if I
know I've got a roof coming up in five
years I need to be setting money aside
for a roof in five years it doesn't need
to like surprise the roof suddenly deter
no it doesn't it unsuddenly deteriorate
deteriorates over decade that's why they
need to be fired they didn't plan well
for this well they didn't plan at all
this is ridiculous yeah horrible
horrible and I I do have a question
because you're in real estate can they
are they the supreme authority the
association says this is what you have
to do is there any no fight back on that
yeah most condo associations and for
that matter regular HOAs have the
ability to do special assessments to
cover okay to cover uh you know
dilapidated mess that they hadn't kept
up the maintenance on yikes but that's
the problem with living in a situation
like that yet one more reason why I
freaking hate HOA Survivor mentioned
that before I hate them complete pain in
the butt all right uh Raymond is with us
in Chicago hi Raymond how are you
I'm great Dave I'm really happy to be
here with you guys thank you how can we
help
well I'm uh uh help help someone I'm
trying to find out something about uh
401k loan I know they are like should
not ever be done and unfortunately when
I went looking for uh information with
you all I found all sorts of reasons why
you shouldn't do it but what about us
the dummies who make the mistake and do
that and when you do the death snowball
I know you're supposed to list things
from smallest to largest I'm I've been
trying to help as many people as I can
because it's worked for us but what I'm
trying to find out is the uh 401K that
seems to have tax ramifications and more
risk even if it's not an IRS problem I
know there's no tax ramifications
whatsoever paying off a 401k loan
oh but isn't there a risk if they lose
their job that they they have to there's
tax ramifications and there's IRS
problems and fees if you have a loan
outstanding but paying it off right
doesn't cause taxes no no that's what I
meant I'm sorry oh yeah yeah there's a
lot of reasons to pay it off when you
leave your company because you died
because you got a better job because you
got fired you will leave your company
when you leave your company uh your loan
is called due in full and you have to
repay it all in 60 days or it's
considered an early withdrawal with 10
penalty in your tax rate on it so yeah
that's one of the reasons it sucks
my question is should it be paid off
earlier or at least be partially paid
off earlier now you can't partially pay
them off you can only pay them monthly
or all at once
so even when you get to it in the debt
snowball you can't incrementally add you
have to pile up cash and savings and
then knock it out in one hit
that's interesting because they're the
workplace says that they can keep paying
it off and they they actually have been
uh paid off you can pay it off you have
your regular monthly payment but you
can't double your monthly payments
huh I've not ever seen one that allows
you to pay extra on it you can pay it
all at once
but um I've never seen one that allows
you to pay extra on it so
um
so folks uh what what Ram is pointing
out is never borrow on your 401k loan if
you do have one put it in the debt
snowball where it goes and when you get
to it you're probably unless Raymond
found an unusual thing you might have I
don't know but most of the time you can
say and I think almost all the time
you're going to find a 401k once you pay
it off in a lump sum so you got ten
thousand dollars you're gonna pay a
thousand dollars a month you're gonna
pile up a thousand dollars a month for
10 months and you're gonna write one
check do away with a 401k loan but yeah
you need to get rid of it wherever it
falls into that snowball and uh dumb
dumb loans really dumb loans they're all
dumb loans but that one's a dumb loan
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Susan's in Mountain
Home Arkansas hi Susan how are you
yourself better than I deserve what's up
well I'm calling to find well thank you
for what you're doing for sharing some
time with me first off I just wanted to
know thank you
um should I pay off my truck yes
um again without anything else well I'll
tell you it's my husband passed last
June and uh thank you
um well I'll tell you he was sick for a
while and then they put him in a nursing
home for rehab and he got covered and I
got it from him I made it but he didn't
so that's pretty much that how long were
you all married hon
uh 32 years we've been best friends
since 1977. wow oh man
how old are you a long time I'll be 65
uh next month the first day of next
month I'm so sorry sorry you're going
through this what what do you owe on
your truck
I have 28 000. we were lucky today
it's very strange
you know used cars cost
what a new car maybe does now I don't
know well ours didn't they were biting
the dust so so
um you have any money
well uh yeah I was caregiver for my
mother also and she left me or her home
and uh I left that was in Phoenix and I
I didn't want to be there anymore and I
didn't have any family there so I moved
to Arkansas I sold that home
um moved uh here and paid cash for my
home I have
um 29
000 in checking 11
000 in savings and forty thousand uh
it's through Edward Jones and money
market and sea beans
and my income is my husband's uh Social
Security because I had quit working you
know to care give for them and it's
about 28 seven a year if you don't have
the car payment can you live on the
Social Security
if you didn't have the car payment can
you make the budget work on the Social
Security
uh yeah I'm gonna have to for at least
for a while I want to go to work but but
uh I
had to put certain things off on myself
you know to take care of them and I've
got to have hand surgery on on each hand
but after that I'm hoping to get back
out in the workplace if somebody I had
me I've been out of it for a while I
guarantee you something they will yes
they will guarantee you they will you're
a jewel
um the okay so what I want to do is I
want to take the money that you have
between Edward Jones checking and
savings and I want to set aside your
checking doesn't need that much money in
it okay we want to set the money over it
let's have an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses so you need an
emergency fund equal to about what your
savings is
about 11 about 11 or 12 000 that will
cover you for three to six months
right okay
okay I wouldn't mind if it's fifteen
thousand okay but somewhere around there
and that leaves you the Edward Jones and
the checking and you've got a twenty
eight thousand dollar loan and a 29 000
in checking so I just write check pay
off the truck today
really I would that panics me but I I
trust you well
you either need to do that or you need
to sell the truck because there's 28 000
loan is destabilizing your finances
right right yeah I'm I was looking at
that last night and I just thought oh my
goodness and the truck you know well you
overpay for anything you buy anymore but
this is if you don't want it and you
want to sell it and move down that's
okay too
well I don't think I could I couldn't
get out of it but what I owe for sure I
mean you might have to write a little
bit of a check but I mean you could end
up with a ten thousand dollar less
vehicle
down in the 15 000 range and uh
you know uh it's possible you could move
down and if you want a little less it's
it's a lot of truck it's a lot it's a
pretty expensive vehicle for your
situation but if you're gonna keep it
you need to pay it off today
okay yeah well you're right bad gas
mileage and
and everything so well you know you keep
talking about how it's you know if I
were in your shoes I'd probably look
start looking and do a little planning
and sell it and get something that you
actually want that has good gas mileage
and is reliable in the 15 10 15 000
range in your situation I think that's
going to be a lot better vehicle I think
you all overbought on vehicle there's a
lot of emotion at the time you bought
for everybody and I think you paid too
much so I probably would move down but
if you're going to keep it you need to
pay it off today and
um so it won't hurt to pay it off today
and then sell it too that's okay too and
trade trade down and you know get you
into ten twelve thousand dollar vehicle
something reliable the gas mileage is
good that you're comfortable with in
your situation as a 66 year old lady
that's by yourself right now so you've
been through a tough time I'm sorry
kiddo we're here to help you though if
you need anything you call us anytime we
will help you any way we can it's it's
what we do here so
wow that's tough yeah and I I agree with
you on just downsizing she doesn't need
a truck for any reason if it were my mom
I'm sitting here thinking let's get her
nice today and get her a nice Toyota
Honda some kind of reliable sedan that's
got low miles very good gas mileage and
as she begins to re-enter life that's
all she needs a Dependable nice little
sedan that gets her from point A to
point B yeah and you can get a lot of
car for 12 14 000 bucks a lot yeah for
half of what she's got this that's right
yeah exactly something to think about
there something to think about but
either way uh that truck payment's going
to be gone either way open phones are
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Leah's in Charlottesville Virginia
hi Leah how are you
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
so I have been wanting to ask you this
question for like weeks um I got an ERC
payment
um I'm a business owner and I got PVP
and like I I did my business the way I
was supposed to and then well not really
the way I was supposed to but I did it
and then covet happened and then I got
all these all this money and I survived
and now I have this I had this big lump
sum of money did I I don't have
employees anymore so I paid off like
twenty thousand dollars worth of debt
and I had like
probably forty thousand dollars worth of
debt left but I have twenty five
thousand dollars in cash and I'm worried
did you meet the guidelines of the PPP
and the ERC to not have to give it back
I did I did okay I did it's clear
so
what else to pay
to pay not not necessarily debt free but
I'm I still have my I only would have
with my car I have a house
um and I do I do a lot of things I I
moved back home with my to my to my
mom's house in my house an hour rental
so
um if you met the guy if you met the
guidelines that they put on that program
then the money's clear if you didn't
meet the guidelines they're going to ask
for it back
right I have an accountant who's great
and I I'm just worried that I'm gonna
they're gonna be like hey and I pay my
student loans so I have nothing I have
no no that I just have like um a couple
credit cards and like you're afraid
they're gonna say hey what
you owe this money well if you met the
guidelines they're not going to say that
if you trust if your accountant has
walked you through the points that you
have to meet on there there's about six
different offerings and I don't know
which one you got but um it was all
screwed up and we were yelling at people
not to take that money but you took it
if you met the guidelines I'm not mad at
you for it
um just make sure you met the guidelines
and that way this thing that's spooking
you in the back of your mind it sounds
like you think you haven't met them
and so you need to be very sure that you
have and very sure they're not going to
ask for the money back and if not
they're not they're not going to just
change it now
um you know there was a lot of
electricity in the air back in those
days uh to say the least but um yeah
it's we've not we've not seen any of our
customers any of the people we're
dealing with where they've gotten into
trouble and
um the government has gone in and
changed the rules after the fact on that
particular program so again go over it
again with your accountant and make sure
and then you're clear this is the Ramsay
show
thank you
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
he is the host of the Ken Coleman show
and author of the number one
best-selling book from paycheck to
purpose he talks to folks about their
jobs and their careers every day on the
Ramsay Network so be sure and call in if
you got something in that area for sure
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five starting this
hour is Tucker in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Tucker how are you
it's okay I'm Doug here doing well how
are you Dave thanks for taking my call
today better than we deserve we're glad
to have you brother how can we help
thanks and hey ultimately my question is
whether or not we should sell our home
uh right now we're newer to the ramsley
Ramsey plan we took uh Financial Peace
course that you guys offered for pastors
online and got the every dollar app and
set up all that stuff good according to
the plan we're on baby steps four five
and six good but our house payment is 35
of our take-home pay so finding the room
to pull out 15 of our income isn't
really something that I've been able to
figure out right now where we're at so
we have some decent equity in our house
that we can pull out if we sold it I
guess where I'm torn is if we sold it
where we would go the rent for a three
bedroom place is the same if not more of
their current house payment and I guess
we could try and find something smaller
it's just still pretty competitive in
the area that we live in you like that
house then
yeah we like our house mirror pasture
yes sir okay all right cool
well here's the thing um there's no
Panic and the last thing I do
uh out of the on if you were to Force
rank if you make a list of things to do
to get your money straightened out the
way down the list of selling the house
because it's very expensive to sell it's
expensive emotionally to move uh it's
expensive financially to move everything
else so it's just uh it's very seldom
the answer to an equation
uh so what does your wife do
well she stays home with our kids right
now how many kids
we have two okay all right
um I I think rather than selling the
house I'm going to look and say okay
what are some short-term things I can do
or we can do in this household and what
are some long-term things we can do to
change our income situation so that the
house becomes a reasonable percentage
you don't have to do it in 20 seconds
it's not like baby step two where you
have to get geared up in gazelle intense
right now you're on four five and six
but the the point of not having a 35
house payment thirty five percent of
your take on pay is it just hard to do
other stuff it's hard to save for the
next car it's hard to save for Christmas
it's hard to say for retirement there's
just not as much room in the budget
because you're more of closer closer to
what we call house poor if you told me
45 I tell you sell it today because I
don't think you're going to turn that
corner but 35 I think you can turn the
corner on this
um over the next year or two or three or
whatever and in the meantime backfill
was some kind of supplemental income uh
and that's not that unusual for a pastor
by the way
to lots of pastors are by vocational as
a matter of fact the numbers that we
have say about 80 percent of them yeah
and my dad did the same uh as we got
older and he wanted to put us in a local
private Christian School that was a
little bit of a stretch he went out and
did some carpentry work about it he was
a pastor about it he was sorry my dad
wasn't and still is a pastor and did
that and and again if you've got family
in the area uh or you've got someone in
the church an older grandmother who'd be
willing to watch the kids for three or
four hours five hours a day to get you
to 20 hours a week to where your wife
can work these are all seasonal
sacrifices that will tip the scales as
Dave was talking about you've got to be
looking at everything possible uh
because short-term and long term that's
right but in the short term Dave I find
that a lot of people don't realize all
the options they have and I'm not sure
what that is you've been doing this a
long time but once we start just saying
basic Common Sense things people begin
to realize okay I can save money here uh
I can make more money over here and we
begin to look at the big picture in the
short term and then long term you know
you're right that is a much different
discussion but the big the big thing
that Tucker did uh if what he was saying
was we had a a series last summer where
we offered Financial Peace University
for free to pastors and you know at that
point he didn't even know he had a
problem so now he's problem aware that's
right that's the first step and that's
good news so we were able to help him
and get get a lot of things moving get
the baby step two cleared out and get
them up to this level and I'm glad we
were able to do that but um yeah now
he's at least problem aware but I don't
think we need to go to the extreme no
not at all yeah and um now if you if you
go 10 years and don't save anything for
retirement
because of this then yeah that's a
problem you're gonna have to think
rethink that so I'm going to make some
adjustments of some kind to get to where
we can start doing us maybe you're doing
12 for retirement for your baby step
four right now but with the idea that if
we did these other three things we could
get to 15 uh eventually as a permanent
sustainable process yeah and that that's
where you need to get to you do need to
get there because you're going to retire
and you do you need a paid for house and
you need a big old 401K plan when you
get there all right Joseph's in Austin
hi Joseph how are you
good how are you doing today better than
we deserve how can we help
so uh I'm 31 years old uh I own my
property
um I've got a good paying job but I've
got two car payments both of them around
eighteen thousand dollars
they're my largest ex probably one of my
largest expenses every month and every
month now ever since we we recently
moved here we're having to cut into our
savings a little bit to just kind of
make it through the month to the next
paycheck you are not on our budget
uh not a good enough budget no you're
not and you're still going out to eat
and all other kinds of crap
not as much as we used to we have if
you're going out to eat it all you're
taking money out of savings to go out to
eat that's dumb
right yep yeah so you guys the first
thing is you need to get on a tight
budget and make some conscious decisions
so what's your household income
uh about a hundred thousand okay all
right
and so which one of these cars do you
want to sell
we don't want to sell either of them uh
we both need our vehicle they're well
you need a vehicle
we need two vehicles for one for I mean
you need a vehicle you don't need the
one you've got necessarily
we don't know I feel like we've paid off
a good amount of them you know uh we
bought both of them when they're
probably above forty thousand dollars
and we owe I think under 18 on each of
them so you go 36 000 on cars you make a
hundred what other debt have you got
um that's that's pretty much our only
debt that city is pretty much I mean
that's the pretty what's the rest of it
events every month would be our property
taxes which is did you say your property
is paid for your house is paid for
our house is paid for correct
and you can't pay car payments
with no house payment making 100 grand
you are real you got you got lifestyle
creep Joseph big time Big Time stop your
401k contributions temporarily
don't go out to eat and don't go on
vacation live on beans and rice rice and
beans get on a detailed Budget on every
dollar download the app you and your
wife sit down and look at this and go
time to be grown-ups adults divisor plan
and follow it children do what feels
good it's time to punch these car
payments in the face to get these stupid
things paid off fast then you'll get
your life back
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thanks for being with us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Maddie is in
Lansing Michigan hi Maddie welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi Dave thanks so much for
so much for sure what's up
uh I am wondering my husband and I are
trying to find our first house and we're
willing to pay up to 200 000 that's kind
of the top of our budget
and we keep putting offers on houses
and we usually have a we do like fifteen
thousand dollars over asking price with
an appraisal guarantee and we keep
striking out on houses
how many times does that happen
um we've been looking for about no how
many offers have you made that you got
beat out on
it's probably I think it's four so far
okay all right and how long have you
been looking
uh just about a month it hasn't been
super long okay it's okay just calm down
don't don't get it don't get crazy
because you missed a couple God's Gonna
God's Gonna serve you up the exact right
one you need you're gonna be just fine
don't because what's going to happen is
you're gonna get all hot and bothered
here and need a cold shower and you're
gonna overpay for something because you
get out of control
chair just calm be calm you got the rest
of your life how old are you
27. you got the rest of your life to get
a house one whole month you've been
working on it
yeah so do you think
do you think you should spend you know
to offer over 15.
yes that's plenty okay that's plenty and
you know if you're getting the right
situation you can look at it but I mean
if you're going to pay 30 000 over
appraisal that's 15 over appraisal on a
20 000 or 200 000 house that's pretty
substantial
sure and so if houses go up seven
percent a year it takes two years for
you to break even on your overpayment
sure
also considered um we looked at one
property and talked to a contractor and
no we are thinking we can okay you don't
think that's even a possibility for the
first time
new housing is always more expensive
when you're buying retail like that from
a contractor than used housing you're
going to get better value used and
you're 27 and it's your first home
purchase building a home is a royal pain
in the butt
and I've built several I'm building one
right now and I'm pretty good at it I'm
pretty good at managing the budget and
the schedule and I grew up in the real
estate and building business and um and
Sharon and I've been married 41 years
and it's still is stressful on us and we
have to be real careful to not fight
[Laughter]
and you're just it's a much smoother
simpler
transaction you're going to get more
bang for the buck and used housing I
wouldn't do it there later on you guys
have been married a while you know you
got you got your life settled out you
you know you want to go into that
adventure of Home Building it's an
adventure because there's 9 000 things
to pick out there's a lot of arguments
about room size and everything else and
uh we have to start every time we start
a project Sharon and I have to raise the
right hand and say I'm not going to kill
you
yeah it's it's stressful and I'm also
not going to kill The Decorator yes or
the contractor or the contractor yeah I
mean we're going to be nice you know
this is fun Maddie Dave gave you great
advice I'm just going to tell you I I
can still remember the first house
station I bought and you know we thought
the we couldn't get a house we had a
same situation and finally the right
house at the right time popped and you
know what it wasn't anything big and
fancy but we have such fond memories of
it and you guys are so young just just
less is more with that first home yeah
it really is there's nothing you don't
have to prove anything with it just and
you're not going to keep it forever
that's the key every anytime somebody
says a forever house I always just laugh
yeah your only forever house is in
heaven I'm just saying because as soon
as you're I've done enough deals with
people like this is my dream house and
since you're moving your dadgum dream
changes this is what happens all right
Andrew's in
Orlando what's upper Andrew how are you
better than I deserved Dave how are you
doing today the same how can I help
well I'm being sued by a credit card
company and I wanted to know what I'm in
for hmm you actually been served
uh not yet I actually found out about it
because a bunch of ambulance Chasers
started sending the advertisements for
their services so I I looked up the law
office called them they claimed to have
no idea what I was talking about so I
went to the county clerk of court and
found the case
so they actually have filed
yes okay all right how much do you owe
the credit card company
twenty thousand dollars roughly why has
it not been paid
um
basically there was a point at which my
ability to to continue paying ran out
um the the short version is after
quarantine my wife and I both got
coveted twice that put us out of a month
of work each time and then my cancer
came back
oh my God every yeah
um for what's worth God is good I'm
cancer-free as of right now oh that's
good but it was one of those things
where every time we climbed out of one
hole something else hit and recently
this past may we got the greatest news
that my wife's pregnant with our first
child but as you can imagine that came
with another set of holes to dig out of
as as we were trying to dig out of the
other holes
well pregnancy doesn't usually cost him
money
much it wouldn't have yeah it the the
doctor's uh appointments we found out
that the insurance we had for her had
been discontinued and that her uh
primary physician had retired and we did
not get they didn't switch us over to a
new primary so we went through a
rigmarole of self-pay with an OB GYN for
the last couple months okay and you're
back to work now after the cancer
remission
yes I'm I'm back at work full time and
uh she is
um
currently attempt to pick up hours with
her clients and she's looking at a
second job as well as hi how's your
energy level
my energy is great luckily I didn't have
to do chemo this was uh good quite a
long search so what do you make
um
together last year we did 58 000 uh I
did 45 of it what do you make now
oh uh roughly 45 a year okay doing what
uh I work as patient care specialist at
an anti-aging Clinic okay what's your
wife do
um she is in uh full-time child care
she's sort of uh almost like a permanent
daily babysitter so you're making you
make 45 and she makes what
uh last year she made roughly 13
um this year
um she's been keeping track of it but I
don't have uh her exact numbers just yet
because the reason I'm poking around is
I'm looking for something to throw at
this these guys okay your best bet is to
offer them about five or six thousand
dollars as a settlement in full because
this is like two or three year old debt
right it's not anything paid on in two
or three years
correct yeah and if you offer them uh
you know quarter on the dollar or so and
you argue with them and fight with them
a little bit you're probably gonna get
it so five or six thousand bucks I'm
assuming you don't have any money though
not at the moment no
what's at the moment mean does it mean
there's some coming
no I mean like we're both looking for a
part-time jobs okay
I didn't know if somebody's getting
ready to send you a check I didn't know
what you're talking about okay oh no
that's that don't be wrong that'd be
lovely yeah that'd be great that'd be
great yeah okay so your best bet is to
settle uh Pennies on the dollar of some
kind 25 35 cents on the dollar
cash on the barrelhead call this people
and argue with them and it'll take about
four phone calls and they're gonna
threaten you and call you everything and
you can settle with them but if you
can't scrape that together the best you
can do is what's called an agreed order
and that is agree to start paying
payments to the law firm and they will
cease the law soon in in terms of an
agreed order that they'll take it before
the judge the judge will approve it if
you miss a payment if Florida allows
garnishment garnishment would be
instantaneous
yeah they do okay I'm pretty sure they
do that's how it works I'm not an
attorney but we've worked probably 10
000 of these with these types of law
firms keep in mind this Law Firm has
zero emotion in this they don't care
about your problems uh all your history
all they care about is you are a widget
on an assembly line they are doing
thousands of these a week thousands so
you are you're you're an item in a
factory for them so that don't they
don't they're not emotional you don't
need to be emotional just try to settle
it per month or scratch up five six
grand somewhere and make them and offer
a settlement in full and you will have
to argue with them
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage
Jacqueline is with us and Jacqueline my
associate producer said happy birthday
to you happy birthday to you and I got
you again happy birthday it's not my
birthday it's your birthday yeah but I
brought you a gift
this is called credit debt cards I love
it yeah that'll work that'll work I
can't wait where are you from I'm from
Dallas Texas how much debt have you paid
off 180
000 just like that yes you're that girl
yes and uh how long did this take it
took me 11 years to get to that point
seven years and your range of income
during that decade it started about 40
and then it ended about 65 000. wow
what do you do for a living I'm in
customer service I'm on the phones okay
cool what kind of debt was this oh it
was some of everything that I had a
HELOC a HELOC I also had a business debt
I had credit cards Chase Freedom Chase
Inc and all sorts of credit cards all of
them I just wanted all of them yeah
so of the 180 what was the biggest debts
my mom oh I forgot my mortgage oh
so uh what's this house worth the house
is worth
365 69 000. you rock yes you rock thank
you and you are paid for I pay for half
now I can go to sleep and rest man
when you're growing up do you ever think
you'd be this rich I
I did
I do
I'm so proud of you yes well done all
right tell us a story what happened here
they got you fired up you plowed through
all these credit cards you plowed
through all this mess and then don't you
just keep going knock out the house well
that um what happened Dave uh back in
I got a very disturbing call I just got
up and went to work I got to work at six
o'clock actually about 6 30 and I
received a call from a little man that a
guy that lived with me I had took in I
took in my friends from school her son
and he was living with me he was needing
to graduate his mom was had a real bad
drug addiction and so I brought him in
my house so he could graduate and he
called me one day when I got to work he
said Miss jacket I knew he kept calling
me and I couldn't answer so finally he
called me so much I finally answered the
call he said Jackie Miss Jackie I just
got a call from the hospital and they
said it was something about your husband
and they needed you to get to the
hospital well the hospital was a known
hospital in our area but it was two of
them so I went it's called Methodist and
I went to the hospital I said well my my
nephew I called my nephew he gave me
told me that I needed to get to the
hospital and I didn't know what no one
knew anything so I'm going through the
hospital just frantic frantic trying to
find that one I finally they said well
let me call the chaplain so the chaplain
came back he said Miss Terry I just need
you to hold on the doctor that was on
duty uh he needs to talk to you but we
have to call him back to the to the
hospital so the doctor came back and
they took me in the back and they said
Miss Terry they was sorry
they told me that they were sorry I'm
sorry
I didn't know I was gonna get emotional
but anyway he told me they were sorry
that they couldn't revive oh my yeah he
was killed in a car accident oh man he
ran into a concrete truck
and he lost his life
and that was the hardest thing that I
had to do I had to go that was 11 years
ago that was 11 years ago and I had to
go home to my children and tell them
that they fall they knew I was holding
something because I didn't know how to
tell them so I had to tell them I called
my pastor and he called us to the church
and they knew something was going on
because of the way I was acting so we
went to the hospital long story show I
went to the hospital I mean to the to my
church and my pastor talked to my
children and then we just had to figure
it out Dave with me and him we were
already struggling trying to make ends
meet we were struggling so I knew I had
to if I wanted something better if I
needed to be the best example to my
children I had to do something different
but I just didn't know what it needed I
didn't know what to do
so one day I went to lunch with a friend
of mine and she showed up to the lunch I
I didn't know her that long but she
showed up with lunch with some envelopes
and I would and she had money in each
envelope and she brought up one envelope
said food so I'm like okay she envelope
cash and I here I go with my credit card
to pay for my food and she pulled her
money out of an envelope so I didn't I
said well what is that she said well I'm
on this Dave Ramsey program so I just
you know I just okay so that when and it
was gone and I didn't see anything else
so then later on in life
I was still struggling struggling trying
to pay this pay that I wake up at my
paycheck would hit my bank account about
six o'clock in the morning so I would
wake up at six o'clock every time I got
paid by 6 30 in 30 minutes I was able to
have my account down to zero because all
I had to do was just a click of a button
click of a button I did that for a long
time and one day I just said you know no
more so I started searching some stuff
on the line about getting out of debt
and guess who pops up
wow and that's that's how I end up
getting hooked up to your program and I
want to tell you one thing Dave I know
you get a lot of criticism I I heard it
I I look at you every day and I know you
get a lot of criticism but remember one
thing day is what you're doing is not
for them it's for people like me that
need to be the best examples they can be
for their children see now I can go and
see I got two beautiful grandchildren
now so I can go as a parent you are a
hero girl I'm so proud of you I can I
can live for them now I can live and not
be in so much fun you don't even have a
mortgage no mortgage at all you are so
weird yeah I am so proud of you I taste
chase out of my life you are you are a
Victor yeah there is no victim in your
walk yes yes you're amazing people call
me they you know when I first went on
your program I stopped going you know I
used to go out to eat all the time with
my stuff not anymore then now they
thought they started calling me cheap
I've been called cheap I've been called
tight but guess what and now what we
call you rich
amen very free come on with that and it
feels good
talk some noise
yes I can what do you tell people I mean
you're you you lose your husband in a
horrible tragedy in a car wreck and as a
widow with two babies you fight your way
through this in 11 years 180 000
including a paid for house you are
amazing what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is the key to
being getting out of debt is is being
true to yourself
and stand within your means also
determination you got to have tenacity
because you don't have tenacity to do
that's the difference between a person
that talk about it you have to be about
it and that's what I had to do I had to
be about I couldn't be no more I can't
talk anymore talk is cheap like they say
talk is cheap
yeah yeah you you that'll preach right
there get it hello yes yes hey we got
the live and give box for you and that's
the baby steps millionaire book which is
what you're going to be next for sure
yes yes I'm excited Total Money Makeover
book you'll be able to give that to
somebody like that lady showed you those
envelopes that time yes you'll be an
inspiration you are an inspiration of
course Financial Peace University same
thing I want you to enjoy all that now
how old are the grandbabies the
grandbabies is seven six and seven yeah
and I love them if I'd have known how
great grandbabies are gonna be I'd been
nicer to their parents yes yes yes yes
yes and they get ready to go they just
saw in school this year yeah Egypt and
heiress hey I love it my babies they are
wonderful hey you're amazing I'm so
proud of you yes thank you so much
overcome so much he was strong armed
your way through it and man what little
bit we had to do with your story we are
honored we're honored to be in your
corner we're honored to be your people
well done and also Dave I did want to
say one thing I do prison ministry so
what I want to do in my goal in life is
to get this material into prison system
amen why they you know people are down
and they they absorb and they just let
that season where they down I want to be
able to take this into the prisons and
that's my goal is to come up with a plan
to get into the prison system will
definitely help you any way we can yes
sir you're amazing all right it's
Jacqueline what a hero Dallas Texas 180
000 paid off in 11 years making 40 to
65. you'll hear her story don't you dare
tell me you can't do it she did it count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
happy birthday to you I love it this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day second
chronicles 15 7 but as for you be strong
and do not give up
for your work will be rewarded
Theodore Roosevelt said when you play
play hard when you work don't play at
all
I heard that one for me I haven't either
you can see him saying that one it fits
exactly I like it a lot very good
Ashley's with us in Kansas City hey
Ashley welcome to the Ramsay show
better than we deserve what's up in your
world
um so I just found you about a month ago
in your teachings Dave and turns out my
grandparents have loved you many many
years
and I have an opportunity to get a job
that will be paying 50 to 55 000 a year
still negotiating that um and I
currently earn 37 pre-tax
um and in in two weeks he'll be on baby
step two but in order if I were to take
this job to transition I would have to
use my baby step one to supplement the
transition to a new job and I just
wanted to know how to take a new job
well just to help so the pay periods are
different so I get paid so the first of
the 15th I get paid on the 15th so that
works so I won't have a paycheck to help
tie over my bills
um
during that two-week change so whenever
I go to the new job it has two weeks
before a pay date
so I get paid when I leave this job but
not
like two weeks after so I'd wait I have
a wait period between jobs for a
paycheck
if you leave the job and you work two
weeks at the new job you should get a
check at the end of that two weeks I
don't understand
you should but without I asked them
about their paydays during interviews
and with how they work there would be
um time between when my bills are due
and when I get paid so I wouldn't get a
paycheck right then so I was wondering
if it was a good idea to take the job if
I have to kind of take a step back yeah
you need to take the job but I'm just
I'm also trying to figure out a way to
work around this if I can yeah how much
time between when you would get the
check and when your bills are due
um about 10 to 12 Days depending on
which bills it is so rent would be 10
days and
um
light yeah call them if you need to
certainly the landlord for sure but most
of these like utilities and things like
that you've probably got a 30-day window
before there would be any charges and so
I don't think this is a big of a deal as
you think it is
oh I've been really nervous about this
I think you need to take the job but I
think you also need to minimize the use
of the cash which is what Ken's pointing
out okay so because I don't I don't want
you to be down to nothing that scares me
uh but I'm gonna take the job anyway
yeah and um so I I um yeah you should be
able to but I I hate for you to be back
to zero I really wouldn't want to do
that
um yeah let me think here uh well while
you're thinking Dave let me throw this
out here Ashley you have the ability to
probably take on some short-term wow
maybe some gigs some I mean I'm sitting
there looking at I'm just going to throw
this out arbitrarily but let's say you
needed uh two thousand dollars the fact
that you're in this to go you know right
now what that number is I'd go make that
money on the side I'd sell some stuff
I'd come up with that money and not
touch my uh emergency fund yeah go go
unfortunately I have two babies under
one one is my foster daughter and one is
my biological daughter so I am going to
take time yes sir wow so you don't have
the margin to do that
to take time out of my day already
because daycare is my work hours and I
don't have the ability to supplement
daycare with anyone else I moved to a
new city about a year ago so I don't
have what is the new job what are you
gonna be doing
um medical software support which is I
have Tech certifications that I got and
I was supposed to be working that about
a year ago but my corporate job then was
like no we don't want to move you so I
moved to where I am now which is medical
reception and then I'll be doing medical
Tech hopefully
so you can't do any gig work at night
after the babies are in bed as it
relates to technical type work
technology stuff because I didn't get
the training experience on the job I
would have to basically just apply
somewhere and get a job with them and
that would just be another job there's
no can you sell some stuff notifications
there's no sorry can you sell some stuff
I already did that to help with baby
step one good well here's the deal uh
look if you can't do that back to what
we were saying you need to get in touch
with all these you look at your
utilities look at everything and you've
got some Grace periods we're talking
about 10 to 12 days you're gainfully
employed yeah you're fine you're gonna
be all right just just don't pay stuff
on time pay it 10 days late uh so that
you're not without cash with two babies
in the house I mean I want you down to
zero so if you use a couple hundred
bucks out of this thing or something to
make one payment on something that's our
on your maybe your rent or certainly
your food that kind of stuff you don't
go without food you don't but if you pay
your light bill 10 days late it's not
the end of the world and the next month
you'll be on time it's not a problem so
Zach is with us in Anaheim California hi
Zach welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Ken I gotta say I'm a huge
fan of you Ken Coleman and your get
clear assessment so I appreciate that my
question is
um how do I increase my income so I can
afford monthly rent out here in Orange
County California because it's very
expensive what are you doing now
I'm a logistics supervisor for a
Manufacturing Company nice okay so you
know your field better than I do but the
gig economy and freelance work right now
would be the first place I look because
it's exploding so with that Logistics uh
background and experience what can you
do uh in addition to what your full-time
job is does something come to mind right
out of the gate
um maybe like part-time work for like a
FedEx warehouse after yeah part-time
work after my full-time job all right
that's one option that's one option
don't limit yourself that's the first
thing you threw out uh Under Pressure
it's a good one but you're looking at
your skill set and you're looking at
your experience and you almost have to
write it out it's a good experience just
to kind of write it out or type it out
on a spreadsheet and go okay this is all
the skill sets I have that I use now or
that I've had in previous jobs and
here's all the experiences so I look at
what's out there now I'm going to make
that money as much as I can and then how
do I get promoted to where I am that's
the other thing what do I have to do to
climb a ladder where I am or within the
industry what do you make
a year
so what would be the number that would
make you feel like you could afford
delivery you are
well to have the rent to income ratio be
25 it would be around 95 000. okay
and you're in logistics supply chain
that's correct which is a
uh exploding field uh and as you
continue to increase your skill set in
that field you should be in the 95 to
125 range uh in Orange County that would
be normal I mean you you're at more of
an entry position within that within
that uh discipline uh but supply chain I
mean it means a lot of different things
when people say supply chain or when
they say Logistics and so but I mean uh
I know high school or college graduates
coming out with a uh a logistics degree
a supply chain degree or walking into
90. uh so you're probably a little bit
behind them in actual technical
knowledge of the discipline so if you'll
continue to grow that long term that's
your answer short term pick up some side
gigs but long term is do what you have
to do to grow your particular knowledge
base in your discipline because you're
in a good discipline you're in a good
field for income production anyway for
to make good money uh it's and it's a
booming field and the beautiful thing
about it is a lot of times you can more
than uh justify your position by how
much you save a company by managing it
well it's absolutely right yeah the
quickest way to get promoted is when
where you are in the now you know a lot
of young people especially it's the
nature of the game certainly being
younger and you're in a new industry
we're always looking for the next thing
the next thing the next thing and the
best way the next thing is the thing you
got right now when when big and and
that's crushing it and going above and
beyond the expectations and showing them
how you make your listen you make the
company more money you we bring up a
great Point Dave I'd be looking for ways
to make my boss's life easier that would
be my number one goal if I could show my
leader hey I'm doing the job you've
asked me to do but I'm here to make your
life easier that's the best way to get a
promotion that comes with a pay bump
well in Inventory management and
procurement and that process our
Logistics person generally shows us
every year how they're worth about four
times what we pay them and it's kind of
something they learn to do in that
business is to show how wonderful they
are and I like it I like it as an
employer I love it yeah that's great
very fun that puts us out of the Ramsey
Show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
thank you
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]